- In Game of Thrones when
Khaleesi's dragons blow out fire,
this is how it happens.
(upbeat music)
- Today we're gonna try the
- Blazing wings challenge.
And we're gonna talk
about our first kisses.
- We're gonna eat the
spiciest of the spicy
in under three minutes.
- [Together] Five wings.
- Three minutes.
Eli said he had the third
spiciest wing of this kind
and couldn't handle that.
- I literally ran to the bathroom crying,
rubbing my tongue with toilet paper.
- What is wrong with me?
I know I don't like this.
I know that this hurts, and I'm excited.
That's a problem.
- Let's go for it, I'm ready.
(suspenseful music)
- Okay, her name was Amanda,
it was first grade and I hated her.
- My first kiss was in front of my,
it was in front of my dad and my grandpa.
- What?
- She would follow me
to my grandma's house
every single day and I hated her guts.
And then one day, she just
grabs me, throws me around,
and gives me the biggest,
nastiest smooch on the lips,
and runs away.
- I was in a play (coughs) Biloxi Blues,
♫ Whoo whoo
My boyfriend in the play,
he wasn't my boyfriend in real life,
he was going off to war and I was
supposed to be his girlfriend,
and he licked his lips
right before he kissed me.
Right as he kissed me I made eye contact
with my grandfater.
- And I knew I would
never forget this day,
'cause this was my first
kiss, and Amanda ruined it.
- I was in eighth grade
swimming in the ocean,
when this guy I liked,
after beach summer camp.
Oh God.
- I was in seventh grade and
there was this guy Ben who
I had a crush on and we were
all playing spin the bottle.
We went to this junior high trip.
- And we kissed in the ocean and I'm
- So we played spin the bottle
and then we waited until
it landed on each other and
we went back and made out
and it was like I had
just put on lip gloss,
so it was the first time
I'd ever worn lip gloss,
and I just remember it being so wet.
I'm crying.
- You kissed in the ocean.
- I kissed in the ocean.
Pretty romantic sounding,
except I freaked out
and I just swam away.
You like someone and then all of a sudden
you just get so scared of the situation.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God I can't do it.
- I can't do it.
- You didn't do it!
- I'm good.
- Oh God.
(soft music)
- This is really telling.
I really am gonna take
this to my therapist.
I wanna eat more wings,
but I'm in so much pain.
- This is not bad, and
then it turned terrible.
- It hurts so bad.
- It still burns.
- I feel fuckin' accomplished.
- I'm so proud of you.
- Thank you.
- The air is worse.
Honestly I think the talking
made it worse for me,
'cause I (screams)
- Don't do it.
- I think my teeth are gonna fall out.
That is not worth a t-shirt.
(upbeat music)